a holly dolly christmas right here  on sunday eight o'clock on channel eight  guys back to you  oh and yeah that was amazing to hear her  involvement with the moderna vaccine and  that development she  was really quiet about that we didn't  know until it was ruled out so  i think a lot of celebrities made  donations for various things but  that one's a very special one yeah  because it's taken a lot of money  nate are you a dolly fan  oh absolutely and in this case dolly is  not an island in the stream  she's been working nine to five to make  sure that we can have our own party two  doors down and enjoy our holly dolly  christmas  oh my god  is 74 you guys unbelievable isn't it  nuts  and her energy no she's just amazing